you've been very open about your battle
with cancer talk about it and you talk
about it in your comedy your stand-up in
your HBO special you do something quite
remarkable you perform topless yeah I do
what what made you decide to do that
well after I had a double mastectomy I
was very uncomfortable with my body and
I didn't have reconstructive surgery and
it just kind of crossed my mind like oh
my gosh what if I did a show topless and
then I was like I can't do that and then
once I got out on the road and I started
touring again it just kept popping up in
my head
take take your shirt off I was being
heckled by my own brain yeah and so I
listened to myself was it at one
performance that you did it for the
first time I tried it out at Largo here
I have a regular in Los Angeles here in
Los Angeles and so I took my shirt off
there and the crowd went nuts and then I
they did they were just like what is
happening
and then I performed in New York at Town
Hall and I took my shirt off there too
and then why not right and so and then
when I did my special for HBO I just
thought everyone should see you know
yeah took my shirt liberating did it
feel like it is I mean it was that I it
was a long process of getting
comfortable with myself as a person and
my body and and then it just it I
there's a statement obviously being made
but I also think it's silly because I I
like to have my shirt off on stage and
just talk about what could be considered
as kind of hacky material in the comedy
world like well that's that's one of my
favorite things is when you do it and
it's such a powerful thing for you to do
but at the same time you intentionally
do some of the corniest jokes yeah but
you have to imagine at the risk of me
sounding corny
you're also it's really good for a lot
of other people too well I've had a
really amazing response from not just
women or a cancer survivors but just men
that are just like this is the greatest
thing like it just it's across the board
it's it's our bodies it's no big deal I
mean cancer is a big deal but at this
point my body is healed and I'm I'm you
know I'm healthy now and it's it's
something to not have taboo around you
may think
[Applause]
all right that's what they want
[Applause]
I love showing people this is with
makeup on and then showing them this is
my shocking truth my actual skin tone
compared to 50 layers of brown paint